[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHET HAASE: Welcome to-- what
are we going to talk about?
Let's talk about Android
development today.
I'm Chet Haase.
I'm on the Android
UI toolkit team.
ROMAIN GUY: And I'm Romain Guy.
I work on the Android team.
I'm working on the new
graphics and layout stuff
that hasn't been announced.
CHET HAASE: How
incredibly vague.
ROMAIN GUY: That's correct.
CHET HAASE: So, today, we're
going to talk specifically
about the naughty bits.
I called it that
because I liked it.
ROMAIN GUY: Because
you have no idea.
CHET HAASE: I had no
idea, at the time.
Like, I don't know what
we're going to talk about.
But, you know what, I like
that title right there.
So we're going to
keep that title.
And we're going to make
it mean, today, basically,
talking about a series
of articles that came out
on medium.com that was a
collaboration of, basically,
a lot of people on the
platform team at Android,
where we tried to do
a brain dump of all
the patterns and anti patterns
that we've seen over the years.
App developers sort of taking
assumptions that they had about
other platforms that they worked
on or other implementations,
using the Java
programming language,
and doing things that
are, essentially, wrong to
do on Android, and ended
up with bad results.
So we put all this information
into an incredibly long
internal document, and
then we split it up
into 10 very long documents
and put them up on medium.com.
So I would encourage
everybody to check those out.
I put up my name there,
just for self-gratification,
but also because you
can, then, find it.
So please check those out.
But, specifically,
today's talk is around
some of the information
in those articles.
About four months ago we
were doing some user group
and said, oh why don't we
do a talk around this thing.
We have about an hour, let's
put all the information
from 9200 pages worth of
information into this talk.
And we went there,
and we gave the talk,
and we got about a third of
the way through in an hour
and a half was gone.
So we're not going
to talk about that.
We've already talked about that.
Let's talk about
some other stuff
that we haven't
talked about yet.
ROMAIN GUY: And,
actually, how many of you
have read those articles
already, just out of curiosity.
CHET HAASE: OK,
the rest of you--
ROMAIN GUY: You can stay.
CHET HAASE: --go read them
now, and we will wait.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: Are they done?
ROMAIN GUY: I think so.
CHET HAASE: OK,
good job everyone.
Now, let's repeat
all that information
in presentation form.
So why is mobile so difficult?
So we want to talk about some
of the higher level ideas.
I would say, if you read nothing
else from that set of articles,
then I would be very unhappy.
But point two is,
I would say, if you
read nothing else except the
first one of those, which
is called "Understanding
the Mobile Context", that's
sort of the bigger ideas of,
not just what the rules are,
but why they actually matter.
What's the context of
developing on mobile
that makes it so very difficult,
and makes these rules so very
important to get a
well-performing and nice user
experience application
for your users?
So let's talk about
some of those things.
So memory, turns
out it's limited.
It's very limited.
So the phones that you have
in your pockets are probably,
I don't know?
ROMAIN GUY: Two or
three gigs of RAM.
CHET HAASE: Yeah, two.
Three?
Is three common now?
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
CHET HAASE: Four, maybe.
Possibly as low as one
in a lot of the world.
512 megs is actually
quite common.
And it's not just common
on the older phones,
it's also common on newer
phones that are being
sold into cheaper markets.
Right there's a weird
thing about Moore's law,
where you assume
that everything's
going to get faster and better.
And, in general, it does, right?
Moore's law does mean that it's
cheaper to make these things,
but it doesn't mean that
the other things go away.
Those same phones are
still in people's pockets,
out there, being used every day.
Moreover, it means
that the low end
to today's sort of
reasonable mid-range phone
is possibly going to be the
low range phone for a long time
to come.
So don't assume that, just
because you got a good deal
on a phone that has a
reasonable amount of memory,
that all of your users
have the same good deal
in their location.
ROMAIN GUY: And something
else that a lot of developers
do, we tend to compare the
specifications of our phones
to computers that we
know and use every day.
So I see a lot of people
saying, three gigabytes
of RAM on my phone.
It's almost as
much as my laptop.
I have four gigabytes
on my laptop.
But, turns out that,
some of our phones today,
they have as many,
or even more pixels,
than a lot of
computers out there.
I mean, even this
morning, I was working
at my workstation that Google.
I have a mac pro, a really beefy
machine with 64 gigs of RAM.
And my 30 inch display
has just as many pixels
on screen as my phone
that sits in my pocket.
And, I actually looked at the
activity monitor on my mac,
and my mac pro was using
20 gigabytes of RAM
to drive the same
display as my phone does.
So we don't have 20 gigabytes
of RAM, just yet, on Android.
We'll get there, someday.
But be very careful when
you make those comparisons,
and it's something we're
going to get back to,
like with CPU's and
GPU's, and storage.
The numbers feel
familiar, but they
don't mean the same thing as
they do on desktop and laptops.
CHET HAASE: Another dynamic
that's important about memory,
on Android, is everybody is
sharing this limited pool.
Right, so if you are
taking up a lot of space
for your activity,
when it launches,
the system may have
to go around and kill
other things to make it possible
for your activity to run.
And then, when you go in
the background, and the user
goes back to the launcher.
That may take a while,
because maybe the launcher
had to be killed in order to
allow your activity to run.
And then, your
activity may also be
killed when those
other activity's
looking for a memory.
Because, if you take
up a lot of memory,
you're going to look really
juicy to the Task Manager, when
it needs more memory to run.
ROMAIN GUY: And
that's very important,
because, I know that
your application is
the most important application.
It is to you.
My applications are my most
important applications.
But I've seen applications
that, basically,
tried to game the system.
And when they're
in the background
they try to refresh
their caches.
Or they do everything they
can to stay around in memory,
so that, when the user gets
back to the application,
they won't suffer
through a cold start up,
so the app is still there.
But, what they do
in the process,
is they kill all the
other apps on the phone,
so they make everybody
else look bad.
So you have to work
with each other.
We really want the
whole experience
on the system to be good.
It's not just about
your apps, not just
about the standard
apps on Android,
it's about the whole
experience throughout the day.
CHET HAASE: Let's
talk about CPU.
It turns out that it's
slower than the CPU's you're
used to on desktop and server,
much, much, much slower.
And, another dynamic that
people don't necessarily realize
is, it's quite often throttled.
So, in order to get the
maximum battery time
that we can out of
these devices, we
end up running things
as slowly as we possibly
can for as long as we can.
So we have clever things on
the system like doze mode
that, hopefully, you heard
about earlier today, that
allows us to just slow
down the entire system
and not do much when the
system is not being used.
But, even when things
are being actively used,
the user is staring at the
screen reading information,
the CPU is probably not
at its highest operating
mode, because we detect that
there is no user interaction,
there's nothing running
that may require that thing.
But that means, in
general, that some
of the things that you may
expect out of a CPU with,
even the speed that it has
on common mobile devices,
may not be true
in all situations.
That you're not going to get
the performance that you thought
you would have in these
common situations.
ROMAIN GUY: I actually recently
got a very interesting question
by email.
Someone was asking
me-- was telling me
that whatever algorithm
he was running
was running slower
than he was expecting.
So I was telling him
that it's probably
throttling, because the
device was not busy enough,
so the CPU was running
probably at 300,
600, 900 megahertz,
something pretty low.
And then he came back to
me saying, it's funny,
when I shake my phone, then
my algorithm runs faster.
And it's true.
When you shake
your phone, you're
probably waking up all
a bunch of sensors,
which are, in turn, waking
up a bunch of processes.
So we bump up the
frequency of the CPU
and your app goes faster.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: So you
could try that,
if you want to send your
e-mail faster, or whatever.
Shake your phone.
Not recommended
to do it all day.
But the reason why we
throttle, its battery life,
but it's also thermal issues.
The latest batch of
CPU's that we have,
they're multiple cores.
And the truth is, if we were
to turn on all the cores
at the same time, at
the maximum frequency,
your device will probably
the melt. Or, hopefully,
reboot before it would melt.
But there's so much energy that
your phone can dissipate that
we cannot run the device at its
full speed.
And be, also, very careful
with the numbers that you
get by looking at
the back of the box,
when you buy your phone.
So you see it's a
two gigahertz CPU.
It is not, because,
most of the time,
we're going to run throttled.
And you're going to
see it has eight cores.
It doesn't.
It has four little
cores, and for big cores,
and we're going to use
some of them at some point,
and some of them
at another point.
We're not going to use all
of them at the same time.
The best way to know what's
going on is to use Systrace.
We covered that,
too, extensively
at various conferences,
and you can probably
find the talks on YouTube.
But Systrace will show you
how many cores are active,
and at what speed
they're running.
And you may be really
surprised by what's going on.
CHET HAASE: I like
the idea of shaking.
Maybe, if you just played
the vibrate thing constantly,
then that would provide enough
shaking to wake the phone.
It's just techniques, just
performance techniques.
All right, let's talk about--
ROMAIN GUY: That
doesn't mean you
should run the vibrator
in your application
when you want it to go faster.
Like that's-- don't
give them ideas.
They're going to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: Maybe I
should hold up my hand,
this is not-- I'm not
being serious, no.
OK see the previous
slide, so all the stuff
that we said about
CPU's certainly
applies to the process
for the GPU, as well.
There's some other
things that are
specific to the graphics side.
For one thing, texture
uploads are very expensive.
A lot of things trigger
texture uploads,
may or may not be obvious.
Whenever we're drawing a path.
Whenever we're entering
new characters of text.
This is the first
time we've seen them.
We're going to draw
them into a bitmap.
That's going to get
uploaded as texture.
Whenever we're doing
vector drawables
or other things that
end up being software
rendered into pads.
Those are all texture
uploads, in addition to
the obvious stuff of bitmaps.
So those are expensive, as are
general fill rate operations.
ROMAIN GUY: Well, it's just
related to the bandwidth.
So just like texture
uploads, we have
a lot of pixels on our devices,
and we need a lot of bandwidths
to be able to feed the display.
And you need to draw
all those pixels.
We need to use internet
buffers, and all that stuff.
And the bandwidths
on mobile has not
growing at the same
speed as the rest
of the system, so the CPU,
the GPU, or even the screen
density.
So it's still very
much a problem, today.
And we covered that
extensively in previous talks
where we mentioned things
like overdraw and blending
and why you should avoid them.
GPU's on mobile
have other issues.
I mean, they're really good.
They're incredible, given
they'll run on phones.
But you can't
really compare them
to desktop GPU's, or your
laptops, or even your consoles.
I mean, just to
give you an idea,
a fairly power efficient
GPU on a desktop
uses about 175 watts of power.
On a phone, if we can
dissipate four watts of power,
it's really good.
We can't do what they can do.
Even if you conserve
the bandwidth,
even if you're really
careful with your textures,
our GPU's are still
very limited in terms
of how many computations
they can do on every pixel.
So, you probably don't care
if you're not writing open GR
code, for instance.
But if you're writing
a game, or open GI
on your application,
something you
need to be very careful about,
especially on older devices.
No matter what, don't test only
on recent devices when it comes
to GPU's.
There's a huge gap
between a Nexus 6P
and devices from two
or three years ago.
CHET HAASE: There's also
an interesting dynamic
that comes up when
you're looking at,
as we said, fill rate that's
not necessarily keeping up
with the curve of
everything else
and these devices
that are coming out
with amazing density.
What was the-- was it the Nexus?
--or the 6P is like 550 DPI.
Just huge numbers, which is
really awesome for a screen
resolution.
But, if you imagine
that that's how many
pixels we have to actually
fill in every single frame,
then that's kind of problematic
if you don't have the bandwidth
to actually do
that appropriately.
Which is why we have a lot of
these recommendations around.
ROMAIN GUY: But the
good news is that, we
felt we were pretty much done
with density, because we have
real so many pixels these days.
But the VR just arrived.
And for VR, you need
even more pixels.
So it's going to get worse.
CHET HAASE:
Fortunately, people only
have two eyes so we
can only go so far.
Memory, so, in general,
a lot of the tips
that we have about
performance boiled down
to tips about memory.
Because, on Android, and the
run times we're talking about,
memory is so closely
tied to performance.
There's a lot of
dynamics around that.
Let's talk about some of those.
So when you require
more and more memory,
you're basically allocating
a larger and larger heap.
It takes more processing
power to actually allocate
that heap to increment
the size over time.
It also means that there's
going to be task thrashing.
We were talking about
this before, if you
take a lot of
memory, someone else
has to die to ensure
that you can live,
and vice versa when you
go in the background.
Allocations are going to take
longer, because there's simply
more information to wade through
for the garbage collector
to actually figure out
where to put the thing,
where the free space is.
Collections are slower
for the same exact reason.
And there's just general
more activity for the garbage
collector to run through,
allocating, collecting, doing,
hopefully not, but
probably, full GC's
to actually get memory
back in the system.
So we thought it would be
useful to walk through some
of the ideas around garbage
allocation and collection
in general so you can
understand the context of why
this stuff costs so very much.
ROMAIN GUY: So this is how
a garbage collector works.
CHET HAASE: OK, any questions?
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: OK, so if we go
into the technical description,
the squigglies on
the left indicate--
actually I don't really know.
I still [INAUDIBLE] something.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, I am
disturbed by the squigglies.
CHET HAASE: Somebody in
the squiggly dimension
is trying to allocate
something, and they come up
with a blue rectangle.
I don't know why it's blue.
I don't know why
it's a rectangle.
But they want to
allocate space for it.
So it looks at the
garbage, at the heap,
and it says, OK, I want
to allocate this thing.
We put it in there,
then we enumerate
all the things that have
references in the enumeration
phase.
The mark phase says, OK,
what are the things that
don't have references, because
those are the things that we
can get rid of.
And then we collect that, right?
So we free up that little
red thing in the middle.
We freed up the space for that.
That is now space that can be
used for a future allocation
in the heap.
It's important to note
that on Dalvik, there's
two different pauses that
happen during this process.
There's a pause
during enumeration,
while you actually walk the heap
and see where the references
are to all these objects.
And then there's the mark
phase that also has a pause.
Part of the mark phases is,
OK, it can do that concurrently
with other threads.
But, part of it,
it needs to pause
everything else in the system
at the end of that mark phase
to, basically, do a post
process and say, OK,
are there any changes since
I ran through the first one?
ROMAIN GUY: And you
want to remember
that a pause pauses all your
threads in your application.
So it's not just the UI thread
that's going to be paused.
We're going to pause
your background threads.
That also means that a
background thread doing
too much GC activity will
impact your UI thread, so
your animations, your layouts.
CHET HAASE: And you can
see these in the log.
These are GC for allocates,
other GC operations,
concurrent GC's.
There's lots of information
about GC's in the log.
You can see some of
these things coming out,
and, if you wonder why
they're there, this is why.
So, on ART, there
were improvements,
huge improvements, made
to garbage collection
allocation in general.
One of the big improvements
was, there is no longer
a pause during the
enumeration phase,
and there is a smaller
pause during mark.
But it is still a
stop the world pause.
So, at the end of
the mark phase,
they're going to do
a quick pause just
to the collect the information
and move on from there.
So, now, let's look at a
more problematic situation.
This is the GC for
Alloc situation.
You come in, someone
wants, yet again,
a blue rectangle allocated.
And it comes in and says, OK,
well I've got a space for that,
how about a second
blue rectangle,
because I had such a good time
allocating for the first one.
And it walks through
the entire heap,
and it cannot find a contiguous
block of space large enough
for the second blue rectangle,
so it needs to free up space
for that.
Then it does a GC for Alloc,
and there's a huge pause, right?
So this is the really
problematic thing about GC.
Not just that it's a huge
pause, but it, basically,
happens at exactly the
time you do not want it to.
You may be in your
inner loop and you're
doing something that
triggers an allocation, that
triggers the need to
actually walk the entire heap
and free everything
possible just to get memory
to allocate that thing.
Nothing can continue
in your program
until that is
freed up for you so
that it can be put on the heap.
So you're, basically,
going to pause right
in the middle of an
animation or a rendering
or whatever, something
on the UI thread.
ROMAIN GUY: And it is important
to know that GC for Alloc
does not make any
guarantee that you'll
be able to actually allocate
what you want to allocate.
Because, if the
heap is fragmented,
and we'll get back to that,
because there's been changes
with ART, between when
the heap is fragmented,
there might not be a
single slot available
that's big enough
to fit your object.
In which case, you
will get a crash,
an out of memory exception.
And, the interesting
part is, you
could have dozens of megabytes
of free space in your heap,
but, because of fragmentation,
allocation could fail and crash
your application,
just because we need
contiguous memory in the heap.
It's actually fairly easy to do.
You can try it for yourself if
you have a developing device.
You can allocate a bunch
of objects in the list,
and then you know every
other object in the list.
You wait for a GC.
So you will have
fragmented the heap.
Try to allocate
another big object,
and you will run out of
memory, even though you
have a ton of memory available.
And that happens a
lot with bitmaps,
which is why, in ART,
they've introduced
the concept of the large heap.
So it's a special heap
for large objects.
And bitmaps, in particular,
are good candidates for that.
So not only does it help
with the heap fragmentation,
because we know that
we're likely to find
large contiguous space
in the large heap,
but it will also make every
allocation and garbage
collection in the coming
heap faster, because there
will be less memory to look at.
CHET HAASE: Another
the dynamic we've
seen a lot is the prevalence of
low-end devices in the world.
In general, we've
referenced this
before in the context of memory.
But, basically, the
device in your pocket,
guaranteed it's faster
than most of your users.
And it has more memory.
So we're talking
about Moore's law.
It doesn't always
apply, or, at least,
it doesn't apply in
the way you expect.
Those low end devices
are going to be
in the world for a
long time to come.
So your application
needs to deal with them,
unless you simply
don't like those users.
Smooth frame rate, so
this is an important one.
We talk about 16
milliseconds a lot.
I guess it's a number
that we like a lot.
Basically, you have
60 frames a second.
That boils down to
16.67 milliseconds
that you have to do everything.
Right, so you need to
process your input.
You need to process your
animations for that frame.
You need to do any
measure in layout that,
hopefully didn't
happen in an animation,
but sometimes it does.
And process all the
drawing commands
for the things that changed.
And then those get sent
over the render thread.
All of that stuff goes through.
Everything has to happen in
16 milliseconds, in addition
to anything else that was
going on in the system that
may cause a pause there.
Right, so 16 milliseconds,
if it doesn't happen by then,
then you just missed
a frame, and you just
missed the opportunity
for a smooth frame rate
for your users.
Another element of frame
rate that's not as obvious
is that consistency is good.
I would say, in
general, it's better
to hit 30 frames a
second consistently,
than it is to hit 60 frames
a second most of the time,
and then occasionally
you're going to pop out.
If you know you're
going to pop out,
and there's nothing
you can do about it,
then go back to the drawing
board and do something about it
anyway.
But it would be better
to sort of back off
to a slower frame
rate, at least one
that you can deliver
consistently.
Otherwise, what
the user is going
to see is, smooth, smooth,
smooth, pause, skip.
Right, it's very
noticeable when you're
going to drop frame
rate, just occasionally.
It's a noticeable
blip on the screen.
ROMAIN GUY: That's
actually something
that, for those of
you who play games,
is something fairly
common in video games,
especially on consoles.
Where video game
developers would rather
target 30 frames
per second, than
have a fluctuating
frame rate, which
can be very distracting when
you need to plan missions,
or have reflexes in
a multiplayer game.
And, the thing is, on Android,
because we are Vsynced,
there are different
types of Vsynced,
but Android has always
been Vsynced, at least
at the compositer level.
When you miss a frame,
it's not like we're
going to drop to 59
frames per second, or 58.
You're going to go all
the way down to 30.
So, if every other
frame, you're going
to go 60 frames, 30
frames, 60 frames,
and it's extremely
jarring for the user.
So like Chet said,
if you cannot hit 60,
you should maybe hit for
30 consistently, instead.
CHET HAASE: Or pop up
a dialogue and tell
them to shake their phone.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: Or have a setting.
CHET HAASE: Let's talk about
run time, so Dalvik verses ART.
We talked about some of the
differences in the collectors,
before.
There's a really
important dynamic
about whether they can
defragment the heap.
So this was sort
of implied before,
but Dalvik, basically,
once you allocate a thing,
if it's going to
stay there, it's
going to stay in exactly
the same place in the heap.
There's no point at
which Dalvik can actually
move things around.
So, if you allocate
a bunch of stuff
and then other stuff
goes away, the stuff
that still allocated
and referenced somewhere
is not going to
move, which means
it can fragment over
time, and, eventually, you
can run out of room to
allocate other items.
Not because you don't have
the space in the heap,
but because you don't
have the contiguous space.
ART made a change where it can
actually defragment that heap.
When the app goes
into the background,
then there's an
appropriate idle time.
So it will, eventually,
compensate for this.
Although, possibly not in the
time that you need it, if it's
in the foreground.
ROMAIN GUY: An
interesting side effect
is that, there used to
be a lot of JNI code
out there that was wrong,
because the objects were never
moving in Dalvik heap.
If you're not careful about
how you get a pointer to,
let's say a java byte
array, your code will work,
because we're never
going to move that array.
Then you move to ART, and
suddenly that array might move,
and your pointer is
pointing to who knows what.
And so, I think the JNI checks
are stricter now, with ART.
So if you write JNI code, or it
you're going to write JNI code,
be very carefully with that.
Make sure you test
on ART and Dalvik,
and follow the JNI conventions
in the documentation.
CHET HAASE: Language
does not equal run time,
and does not equal hardware.
So I gave a different
variation of this talk
at a conference a month ago
and someone asked a question
afterwards along
the lines of, so
when there's a new
release with the JDK
how do you keep up
with the changes
in the run time of something.
And I realized,
people didn't quite
understand the mental
model they needed to
about what the
language is versus
the runtime versus the
devices that we're running on.
So I thought it would be worth
diagramming this for you.
So these are all very
separate things, right?
So we have this Java
programming language
that we use in Android
that has absolutely nothing
to do with the run times
on other platforms.
The runtime is a separate
thing, whether it's
Dalvik, whether it's ART,
whether it's some other runtime
on some other system.
And then there's the hardware
that it's running on,
and it's sort of
important to understand
that this stack is going to look
quite different for servers.
So traditional Java
developers that
are writing Java on
the back for servers,
writing web apps,
whatever, they're
going to be in a very different
environment than we're
in on Android.
So they are running over there
with some server runtime.
It's moving, and it's
a compacting collector.
It's got huge
heaps to deal with,
and it deals of them
very efficiently,
with the very different
system than we
have in either Dalvik or ART.
And then, you're on the server
and the CPU is really quick,
and the memory is,
essentially, unlimited, right?
Just huge gobs of memory that
you can do oodles of things
with.
Meanwhile, on
Android, which you can
tell because it's
colored green, we
have two different run times.
We have Dalvik up until KitKat.
I think ART it was
default in KitKat.
So what the dynamics
are going to get around,
the runtime, the performance of
the runtime, the optimizations
taken, as well as some of the
garbage collector softwares
we're talking about, depends
on which of those run times
you're running on.
And then there's
the actual hardware
that you're running on.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: It's even
shaped like a phone.
CHET HAASE: It is.
It's very accurate.
I took that from the tool.
It's a snapshot from the tool.
So we have no compaction,
as we're talking about.
We do not compact the heap.
We can't be
fragmented on Dalvik.
We can do idle time
compaction when
the app is in the
background with the ART--
ROMAIN GUY: So that
is very important,
because we do compact the heap.
Because it's an
expensive operation,
it happens, like Chet said, when
your app is in the background.
So that means you
can still run out
of memory with a ton of free
memory in your heap, when
you're in the foreground.
So you still need to be very
careful with how you allocate
and deallocate objects,
because you could run into one
of those weird crash
reports that you'll
get from your favorite
[INAUDIBLE] reporting tools,
and you will not understand how
it can be run out of memory,
and this is probably why.
And, of course, do not
send your application
to the background automatically
to defragment your heap.
That's a bad idea.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: Any idea you might
have based on what we say,
don't do it.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: If we
were to quantify
the CPU for this platform,
it would be way slower.
And the memory is, in general,
between 512 and two, or more.
But it's really
important to remember--
ROMAIN GUY: The technical
term is not enough.
CHET HAASE: Not enough.
Never enough.
Also, on the UI thread,
some dynamics here,
it's a single threaded UI
system for the most part.
ROMAIN GUY: Well, it's a
single threaded UI system,
except there's a render
thread, and you can
have multiple single threads.
CHET HAASE: OK so it's
a single threaded,
multithreaded UI system.
In general, you are always
doing things UI related,
which means input processing,
animation, rendering on the UI
thread.
In general, it's a
single UI thread.
ROMAIN GUY: Well,
little know fact,
you can have multiple UI
threads in your process.
Don't try to do this.
It's only frame work people
who have to worry about.
You can, but don't do it.
CHET HAASE: We have
to test for it,
but it's not really a situation
that comes up very often.
When we are done with processing
all the rendering stuff,
then we'll send it
over the render thread,
which will then send it to GL.
But you can still think of it
as being a single threaded UI
system where all this stuff
sort of has to happen serially.
And the trick, here, is to,
basically, eliminate everything
that should not or does not
have to happen on the UI thread,
because you really don't
want to stall that.
Otherwise you're going
to cross that magical 16
millisecond boundary and jank
the UI experience for the--
ROMAIN GUY: So the best way
to make your app go faster
is to stop writing code.
So just go on vacation.
And the best part is,
you can even justify it.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: So, in storage,
performance varies.
So just the raw performance
of these storage devices,
we've also seen situations
where the more that's
been allocated into
that storage system,
the longer it takes
to deal with it.
ROMAIN GUY: If
you're interested,
you should look up
how non Flash works.
It's pretty interesting.
So the disk controllers
for Flash memory
are extremely complicated.
It turns out that Flash
memory is basically
as a garbage collector.
It's very interesting,
but the fact
is that, the fuller your storage
is, the slower it can get.
And things that multiple
random writes on the Flash
can really kill performance.
So, what happens is that, when
you have a lot of processes
on the system, on Android for
instance, that they're writing
to memory, to storage
memory, at the same time,
things will really slow down.
And we've had pretty bad issues
on past devices with that.
It's mostly fixed these days.
But so, if your app
stays in the background,
and you're going
to do a lot of disk
I/O-- try to be mindful of
the other apps, as well.
Because you writing
stuff to the storage
might impact the app
in the foreground.
CHET HAASE: That dynamic
of storage makes sense.
If you just think
about this week,
Thanksgiving week in
particular, as people eat more,
they get slower.
[LAUGHTER]
Storage size varies,
so you're not
exactly sure what your
user is going to have.
Is your app going to be able
to cope with that flexibility?
And the APK size ends
up mattering because
of these dynamics, right?
Are you really going to be able
to fit on the user's device?
And will there be noticeable
performance problems
because it was just too bloated
for that particular performance
dynamic on their system?
In the network,
again, this is just
like the CPU and memory issues.
Turns out your
network is probably
faster than your users'
networks, especially
in some locales
across the world.
They're dealing with incredibly
slow networks or data networks
that, even when they're not
that slow, they may cost a lot.
So maybe those users are not
on those networks as much
as possible.
ROMAIN GUY: A good way to test,
so you can use the emulator.
You've seen the
presentations before.
So there are ways to
emulate slower networks.
Well, if you're
leaving the Bay Area
you could just go take a hike on
the hills, by the 280 highway.
The network is really bad there.
So it's a good way to test,
and take some fresh air.
And, again, you can
justify it with your boss.
[LAUGHTER]
CHET HAASE: Cheaper too,
this is a huge dynamic.
Like, are you trying to sell
your application into places
where they really try
to avoid using the data
network for whatever reason?
But are you very dependent
upon that for your application
experience?
Maybe there are ways that you
could write your application
such that you can deal
with this situation better.
Allow them to wait until
they're on a Wi-Fi network
to deal with that, or whatever.
And finally there's a couple
of-- these sort of marketing
slogans, but they're really
important to keep in mind.
One is, every device
is a village, right?
This isn't just a touchy-feely
thing, this is a reality.
That all of these activities
need to live together,
and services need to live
together on the same system
to make a reasonable
experience for the user.
So, if your activity is
demanding a lot of memory,
you're going to kick a
lot of other stuff out.
So, that's great for
your activity, when
it's in the
foreground, because it
got the memory that it wanted.
But, you know what, when the
user leaves your activity,
and goes back, and has
to relaunch launcher
because it even kicked that out,
because you asked for so much,
that's probably not a
great experience, right?
You're not contributing
to happiness for the user
just because your
application was being greedy.
And then when you go
in the background, when
they run anything
else, you're activity
is taking up so much
memory, that you're probably
going to be killed as well.
So, if all of these
things are going
to be as greedy as possible
in this shared space,
then it's just not going to
be a happy situation, overall.
ROMAIN GUY: And
there are many ways
you can deal with it fairly
easily and fairly efficiently.
So I'm not going to name the
application, because I think
it's one of ours, but I have
a test device, it's a Nexus 9,
and I haven't even set up
a Google account on it.
And every time I
boot the device,
there's a process running that
clearly shouldn't be there,
because I don't even have an
account for that application.
So there's a service running.
So, what you can do in your
application, in your manifest,
you can disable things like
the broadcast receivers,
the services.
And until the user
actually does something
in the application
that informs you
that they want to use the
application, they signed in,
they logged in,
or whatever, then
you can programmatically enable
your service or your broadcast
receiver and the system
will remember that.
So, even across reboots,
your service will stay there.
And it's really important,
because, that way,
you will leave the
rest of the system
free when the user is not that
interested in part of your app.
CHET HAASE: App Standby
tries to address
some of this dynamic,
where, if we notice
that an application
is not actually
being used by the user, then it
will not allow that application
to start using our resources.
Because, obviously,
the user has not
requested that on
the app's behalf.
But there's only
so much that we can
do systematically and
automatically in the system.
Your application knows
better what it needs
and what it can disable.
And then, finally,
the first item
sort of leads to the second
which is, tragedy of commons,
where if every
application on the device
is acting greedily in
its own self-interest,
then you just end up
with a bad experience
overall, for every one
of those applications.
Maybe it made sense for
you, because, obviously,
the most important thing the
user could do on their phone
is to play your cat
video application.
But if everybody has
the same attitude,
then it's going to end
up being bad overall.
So let's go through some tips.
So these are the
higher level concepts
of why this stuff matters.
Now let's go through some
of the actual items about--
ROMAIN GUY: And, hopefully,
you have heard of those tips
before.
So, if you feel like
we're repeating ourselves,
that's a good thing.
And we're going to
talk about it again,
until you stop making
those mistakes.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAIN GUY: So, no overdraw.
How many of you know
what overdraw is about?
CHET HAASE: Well, it's getting--
ROMAIN GUY: Better every year.
Everybody who didn't raise their
hand, shame on you, as usual.
CHET HAASE: Oh,
it's because they're
busy reading the articles.
ROMAIN GUY: I hope.
So, if you want to know more,
I wrote an extensive piece
on the subject.
Just Google, I don't
know, Android overdraw.
You'll find it.
Basically, overdraw
is when you're
repeating the same pixels
over and over again.
We have tools on your phone
that help you catch overdraw,
and we have multiple articles
that explain how to avoid it.
Since KitKat, the
rendering pipeline
does some automatic
removal of overdraw.
It's not perfect.
There are things that
we cannot guess for you.
And, when you turn on
the overdraw detection
tool on the device,
it has the side effect
of disabling the optimization
so you can actually
see where you are overdrawing.
And the reasoning is,
if you're overdrawing,
your also probably
creating too many views,
running bitmaps
you might not need,
making allocations
you don't need.
So fixing overdraw
will also help
other parts of your application,
like memory pressure, startup
time.
CHET HAASE: No
window backgrounds
may seem like a good
idea at the time.
They tend to--
ROMAIN GUY: It was a good
idea a long time ago.
CHET HAASE: They tend to
create artifacts on the screen.
So, if you've ever
seen something
like when the keyboard
comes up, you'll
see either garbage or black
on the window in the space
where the keyboard
is animating over,
it's because someone decided
to assign a null window
background.
This is partly to
address the overdraw.
They said, well, obviously,
I don't want a background
to my window that
is then covered
with an opaque background
of my main container,
so I'm just going to remove
one of them to get rid of that.
And it kind of
works in the main,
but then there's these
specific cases where
it causes artifacts,
keyboard animates up,
and the window manager doesn't
know what to draw there
because you told us null.
Right, so how do
you draw a null?
You don't do anything.
So we don't do anything,
and then the GPU
will just draw
some default there,
which is either
black or garbage.
So there's other situations that
can trigger that same artifact.
The real way to handle
this is to actually have
a window background,
and not have
opaque on that main container.
So you can still get
the benefit of having
the background for the windows
so the window manager always
knows what to draw when it
needs to, but then actually use
that background as part of the
background of your application.
Similarly, there's
artifacts caused
by disabling the
starting window.
Let's see, so the
main reason-- there
are a few reasons to think
about the starting window.
One is that you want to give
the user immediate response
that something has happened.
They tapped the
icon, they're trying
to launch your application,
which, unfortunately,
is going to take seven seconds
to launch because there's
entirely too much happening
when you're creating activity.
But, in the meantime,
we'd like to show them
that something is happening, so
that they don't go and tap it
again and wonder
what's going on,
and then uninstall your app.
So we quickly launch
the starting window,
this takes a very
small amount of time,
usually along the
lines of 200 to 400
millisecond to bring
up this window.
We basically peek
into the resources,
into the theme of the
activity, and we say,
OK, here's what a
window would generally
look like for this activity.
And we'll pull it up
there, and then we'll
cross fade into the activity
as soon as it's ready to draw.
And this includes, for example,
the launch window experience,
if you've seen any of the
stuff running on M. We're
doing the same exact thing.
It's just a starting window
with a background that
happens to have an icon in it.
It's very quick for us to
figure out what this is,
to load it in, and to
launch that starting window.
And then we're cross-fading into
the activity as soon as we can.
If you disable that
starting window,
then there's situations where,
like the launch experience,
where we really should be
drawing something for the user,
and we cannot because
you told us not to.
UI stalls, so this
relates to the single
threaded, multithreaded
UI thread situation
that we talked about.
Or there's lots
of things that can
cause us to stall in the
middle of doing UI processing,
so it's good to
be wary of these.
When you're inflating resources,
that's always on the UI thread.
So, if you're doing a
particularly expensive
inflation, if you're launching
a super expensive activity
from another activity,
or if you have
a deep hierarchy that you're
inflating along the way,
then that may take
enough time that you're
going to jank a frame
because of that.
Handling events, you want to?
I've been talking for a while.
You talk.
ROMAIN GUY: There
are some places
where expensive
operations won't be
that noticeable, for instance
when you click on a button.
But then, the places where
you want a really be careful,
so handling events, like we just
talked about, so on touch even.
Then there's the
all measure method
that's part of the layout.
So you can keep going
through the slides.
CHET HAASE: Here we go.
ROMAIN GUY: OK, the on layout,
the on draw, keep going,
and animations, of
course, are going
to trigger all those callbacks.
So those are really
the places where
you want to optimize your code.
Where you want to use
Systrace, use the profiler,
use the GPU profiler, if you
have to, use tracer for GLES.
And it's OK, I think, to
apply some micro optimizations
in the spaces of code,
because they are so important.
Like Chet mentioned,
you have 16 milliseconds
to do everything you have to do.
And, turns out, that in the
land of mobile, 16 milliseconds
have a different duration.
So, depending on how
fast your CPU's going,
a millisecond might not to be
the same as the frame before.
So 16 milliseconds, sometimes,
will be really hard to hit.
You might also run into issues,
and that's an interesting one,
where, if you optimized
your code too much,
we're going to
slow down the CPU,
so then your code is
going to run slower,
and then you're not going to
be able to go fast enough.
That happened to us before.
And so, the system tries
to take that into account,
but if you run into
that, well, good luck.
CHET HAASE: Be scrappy,
avoid doing too much stuff.
Complex view hierarchy is,
basically, the more views
you have in there, the more
containers the deeper nested
your hierarchy, the more stuff
we're doing on your behalf.
Traversing, had to figure
out and validation, to do
measure, and layout,
and all that stuff.
ROMAIN GUY: And one of the--
so one of the worst things you
can do, and this
is probably why we
make that the default when you
create an activity in Android
Studio is to use
a RelativeLayout
at the top of your tree.
[LAUGHTER]
So if you go file a new
layout in Android Studio,
just do select all, delete,
and start from scratch.
CHET HAASE: Do you know
why we put it there?
It's a test.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
And you all failed it.
RelativeLayout in a lot
of cases, not all of them,
will measure the children twice.
And so, what happens when you
measure the children twice
is that, some of those childrens
are view groups themselves,
like LinearLayouts
or RelativeLayouts.
And those cause their own
children to be measured twice,
then those childrens have been
measured four times already.
So we have some optimizations
in the framework
to alleviate that issue.
Especially starting with
KitKat, the optimizations
have gotten a lot better.
But you can imagine that, if
you have 10, 12, or 16 nested
layouts, and every one of them
measures the children twice,
you're going to spend a
lot of time doing your
measuring your layout.
So be careful with
RelativeLayout,
and LinearLayout.
If you use the weight attribute,
any child with a weight
will be measured twice.
So just be careful,
measure profile,
and try to find a different
way of doing your layout
if you can.
CHET HAASE: Please launch
your activities fast.
Present the UI quickly.
So that's certainly the
purpose of the starting window,
but it's also nice if you
can present the real content
as quickly as possible so the
user is not sitting there,
waiting for your amazing
cat video application.
Defer extra work.
We see a lot of activities
or application code
that's doing a lot at start up.
It has a static block where it's
initializing a bunch of stuff
that it's going to
need eventually.
Allocate it eventually, right?
You don't have to do that
at start up, and make
the user wait every time
they launch this thing.
Instead, you can wait and do it
incrementally, as they actually
need these things instead.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, I can
give you one example
of a the way the launcher
application, at least,
used to work.
I don't know about
the current launcher.
But, back in the old days,
loading all the icons
from this, from all APK's to
present the greed of icons
was extremely expensive and
it took several seconds.
So, what launcher was doing was,
loading three icons at a time.
And after loading
three icons, it
would post a message
in the UI queue
to ask itself to go load
the next three icons.
So, if you're fast enough, and
you open the grid of icons,
you would see them be unloaded
by batches of three or six.
But that was the
idea, so we could
start the application
itself really quickly,
under half a second.
But then, it would keep
building it's own UI
kind of under the hood.
And, if you do it
right, a lot of it
will be off screen, anyway.
And, I'm sure, most
of you have never
noticed that we are doing that.
So, in a lot of
situations, you can
try to use one of those tricks.
CHET HAASE: Measure
cold start, so you
want to figure out how long
it's taking for your application
to launch.
And then, work on that, optimize
it, make sure that it's faster
than seven seconds.
But then, how do you actually
verify that your work has
been worth it?
If you launch the application
and time that thing,
and, actually, I posted
something on my blog
recently, a couple
weeks ago, about ways
that, basically, there's
a really helpful log,
now, that will just tell you
how long this thing took.
And then, some of the details
about that, I put on my blog,
recently.
Anyway, measure that on launch,
and see what that number is.
And then, if you put
that in the background,
and then you launch it
from the icon again,
that's not the same number.
That's called a warm start.
Right, that activity
is already loaded.
We're not actually
doing much work
to bring it up when
it's still in memory,
and still sort of running
in the background.
So, instead, you
want to swipe it out.
Just bring up recents
and swipe it out,
and that will get you,
mostly, to the situation
that you get on reboot, which
is running for the first time.
Because that's really
what you want to measure.
You want to measure
bringing in all your code,
doing all your static
initialization,
going through everything
that an activity does,
every time it launches for
the first time after boot.
ROMAIN GUY: And, once again, one
of the best tools you can use
is Systrace.
I remember, we once identified
an issue in the start
up time of an application.
And the interesting
thing that was happening
was, the application
was using a background
thread to offload
some of the work,
to defer some of the work.
But, at some point,
the UI thread
needed the result from
that background thread.
So the UI thread was
synchronizing on the background
thread.
But, by definition,
the background thread
has a lower priority, so the
UI thread was mostly idle,
waiting for lower priority
background thread to be done.
So be careful with
that kind of issue.
Use Systrace.
Systrace will make
it very obvious when
something like this happens.
CHET HAASE: So some interaction
points to go over, allow
the user to actually get
out of immersive mode,
otherwise it's a
little frustrating.
Immersive mode is
there for a reason,
for full screen video
experiences or games,
but it's also nice to actually
let the users out of the box,
occasionally.
So we've seen this, where
the starting window-- like
when applications don't
disable the starting window,
they don't necessarily do
the right thing with it.
One of the worst
launch experiences
I've seen from
several applications
is, typically, a game
will have, like, they
want to do their own
splash screen that's tuned
to their application thing.
So they have their
splash screen,
and then they have their game
screen, which is quite a bit
different from that,
you can sort of
see how they're related.
But, the best of
all is, they also
have the starting
window, which has nothing
to do with the other ones.
So you get a starting
window up with some default
theme that looks nothing
like the rest of the game.
ROMAIN GUY: And, usually, in
games, the starting window
you get is the
Gingerbread Starting
Window, which is very sad.
CHET HAASE: So don't
go with the sad window.
So they'll bring up this one,
then, after three seconds,
they'll bring out their
own splash screen,
then they bring up their own.
Much better to actually
set the information
in the starting window
to actually look
like the rest of
the application,
whether it's the
status, or the nav bars,
or just the themes and the
style attributes, overall.
Just make it look like
it actually belongs.
Or, even better, if you want
a splash screen experience,
just tune the starting window
to be that splash screen
experience instead.
ROMAIN GUY: So, essentially,
when in your own create,
you find yourself changing
styling, changing the title,
the background of the window.
You probably want to
do that from the theme,
instead, in your manifest.
There are sometimes good
reason to do it in [INAUDIBLE]
because you're computing
data, but, every time you can,
do it in XML instead,
and you'll get
the correct starting window.
CHET HAASE: Cache
your data locally.
So don't make it necessary
to go back to the server
and get that information again.
We saw a demonstration
of this in Adam
and [INAUDIBLE]
talk from yesterday.
So, if you're going to
get that information,
you went to a lot of
trouble to get it,
wouldn't it be nice if
you kept it locally,
so that, if a user goes back
to that information again,
we don't have to make
another query across it.
And also, cache
the input locally.
So, if the user has input some
information into the system,
make sure that you
retain that, so that,
if there is something later that
depends on that information,
we haven't simply
lost it along the way.
We have exactly 20 seconds to
go and about 12 more slides,
each of which is going
to take five minutes.
ROMAIN GUY: So the fewer slides
we put in our presentations,
the longer we talk
about each slide.
So, next time we'll
have one slide.
CHET HAASE: I think we'll
call it a day there.
Thanks very much.
We'll be outside, if
you have any questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]